-And finally,
it is Tuesday, guys.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Yeah, I see
you grabbed them already.
Perfect.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them,
as long as you have fun.
I mean, that's what
it's all about, really.
We're gonna see
the results live, so I can tell
who's really playing the game
and who's not.
Higgins, Roots,
you all have your clickers?
-Got it, got it.
-Oh, yeah.
-Tariq, you've been pretty good.
-I have been --
Well, I've been damn good.
-Yeah.
I'd say you're
in the 90 percentile.
-Yeah, man.
-Higgins, I put you in the
maybe 70 percentile.
-Sure.
[ Laughter ]
But, I mean,
you could up your game tonight.
-I'm going to.
I'm gonna get 100% of this one.
-All right, here we go.
-Whoa.
-Yes!
-Whatever tweet gets
the most likes, we're gonna
tweet it out live on the show,
so that you can all like it,
and we can WeTweet it.
-Oh.
[ Cheers ]
-It's a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
The first tweet is...
[ Light laughter ]
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I think we all know
the answer to that one.
♪♪
-I mean,
there's a lot of discussion.
There's discussion.
I'm gonna give it thumbs up
just 'cause why not.
-You'll only get two.
-Well, you know it's not working
when you have to ask your tailor
to get, "Yeah, yeah, yeah,
I need a little extension
on the Fitbit."
So, yeah.
-No, let out your Fitbit.
-That's correct.
-You're giving a thumbs up?
-Absolutely, I am.
-A pity thumbs up.
-That makes one.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You think it's --
You think it's a landslide?
-Ahmir gave it a thumbs up, too,
so I think two.
-Yeah, 'cause he's a --
he's a caring, giving dude.
-Yeah, not a landslide.
-I'm gonna say less than
50 people.
-Yeah.
The opposite of a landslide.
-Mudslide.
[ Laughter ]
-That's technically a landslide.
-That's basically a landslide.
-It's not mud, though.
-No, it's not.
Okay.
You're thinking really bad.
Under 50?
-Yes.
-All right,
let's see the results.
Votes are in.
-Whoo!
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Whoo-hoo-hoo.
Another one!
-Tough audience.
Tough audience.
They're, like,
really making decisions.
Again, these, yeah, okay,
vote on things for fun, too.
Yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
So, that one's not --
we're not gonna wetweet that.
-Right.
Let out your Fitbit?
It has a strap on it.
-There you go, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't need to let it out.
It's already adjustable.
You know what I mean?
-Yep.
-What's that?
-Like, I went to the tailor,
said, "Can you let out my belt?"
-Yeah.
-No, it doesn't work,
because my belt is --
it's adjustable with a strap.
-The results are already in.
You're not -- there's no --
-I'm just saying.
All right.
I don't want to beat
a dead horse.
I'm sorry.
You know what?
Yeah, my fault.
I'm bad.
Go.
-You don't want to beat
a dead horse?
-No, I don't.
But...
-But seriously, though.
[ Laughter ]
After the show, if...
-Yeah, but, you know,
while we're here...
"Let out my Fitbit."
Okay.
And also, you don't go
to a tailor for a Fit--
[ Laughter ]
-Never mind, never mind.
-No, I do.
-Right, sure.
-I do.
-Yeah.
Yeah, sure, you do.
-That's right. I go
talk to my tailor every day.
[ Laughter ]
-Your solid-gold Fitbit band.
-We make jokes.
-Yeah, it's diamond encrusted.
-Yeah.
-We make jokes, yeah.
-You and your tailor chat.
-All right, here we go.
So you don't have to vote
for that one.
But here's the other ones.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
How about this one here?
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
-[ Laughing ]
-No.
-This is gonna be
the opposite of last week.
-Dude, I think all these
are yours this week, Jimmy.
-No, no. What you do mean
all of these are mine this week?
[ Laughter ]
"You're putting in werk."
-How did you write these?
-W-E-R-K.
-Yeah, "werk."
-Werk.
-Like Luke.
-Yep, I think this one's gonna
be up past at least 40.
-It might be 43.
-I'm gonna say it's like 50%.
50/50 on this one.
Let's see this results.
-50 perc--
Whoa!
-Oh, man!
♪♪
It's a lot of werk.
Glasses, mask -- a lot of werk.
Too much werk for the ears.
I like that one.
Not bad.
All right, next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-It's hard writing jokes.
-Yeah, it really is.
I don't feel good about this.
Let's see the results.
-Oh, my goodness!
-I love you guys.
I love you guys.
You're playing the game.
All right.
How about --
How about this next one here?
I think you might like
this next one. Ready?
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one.
♪♪
-Some people
are dancing to this one.
Some people are
dancing to this one.
This one feels promising.
-Yeah, this was really good.
-I feel like everyone
came in together.
-Yeah.
-They united on this one.
We just united the States
of America right now...
-Yeah.
-...on this tweet.
Let's see the results.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo-hoo-hoo!
-All right, here's the last one.
Here it says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I'm gonna give that a yes, too.
-I think --
-I love that one.
-I think that's the winner.
I think that
is the actual winner.
-You think that's the winner
more so than chickpeas?
-I said it after we all voted.
-All right.
-I did not influence the vote.
I just got --
Someone just did this to me.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-I do not agree.
I think it's gonna be
almost a landslide.
-What was the last one?
What was the last one?
160 something?
-182.
-Wow.
-I'm gonna say this is 1--
1-- 190.
-Ooh.
Let's see it.
-Okay.
-Wow.
-1-9-0.
-Let's see the results.
Oh!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It only takes one!
That's what I'm talking about!
Yeah!
Very nice.
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet, and enjoy.